- hello this is the greatest show ever
made and I want to thank the Emmy
Council the Emmys for nominating us for
best show of all time which we won
graciously so thank you to the Emmys
that they get everyone who voted for us
and congratulations to you know for Best
co-host on the universe ever other
powers I think you totally deserved it
and I'm very proud of you and of course
I won the best host of any show that
ever existed which I'm very grateful as
well so thank you all and and the
audience one they want best audience to
ever watch the show
they are the rest so congratulations we
all want Emmys this year they do to our
sponsors who want best sponsors of the
everything ever sponsored a show
privacy door - and stamps calm thank you
to them we've got a lot on the dock
today my dudes
my throat is messed up by the way I
think it was the forest fires come on
with the Disney trip yelling at full
blast for nine hours and I've just been
coughing up this like putrid mustard
green like I showed Ella I saw it and
looks it's bad wrong yeah it looks wrong
like brown it's so bad I took a bunch at
nyquil yesterday or not nyquil but
there's this beverage I was drinking
ther a few flew like a beverage
I just been hitting a [ __ ] hard and I'm
out of it more than last week just
disclaimer we're just gonna make excuses
now every week no I will feel better
eventually
okay and I'll let people know - this is
the feeling better episode but this is
the feeling bad episode today we're
gonna talk about Tricia she made an
apology video for saying that she was
trans just so called me out no no that's
all see my reaction video to ice yeah
I'm sorry she made a reaction video to
me to the claim now she says this is an
abstention she ated claim that she has a
20-inch engorged [ __ ] that goes down to
her toes
drags on the floor when she walks she
actually post the pictures of itself she
tweeted them to me I can't show you guys
it's it's disgusting I said I respond to
her tweet I just said gross Wow
but it's funny cuz all of their
responses are people like dude this is
horrid
well we're not even talking about it yet
oh and then more exciting just the
preview Ian the intern ran into Belle
Delphine at the white at the can I say
it Awards the awards the pH or Wow the
pop Awards adult industry awards either
tone-tone sandwich friendly show yeah
adult industry awards Ian ran into Belle
Delphine he got a photo with her and
he's got a story to tell us that's
coming up
it's all here today on the h3 podcast
experience did that work again
this in a minute doctor yeah why don't
you have a seat right over there boom
and there who else has got gazebo game
like that nobody now before we get
started I've got another scooter video
surprise surprise Ethan wow you're
obsessed with scooters yeah I am watch
this video if you think that it's not
hilarious watch how it's perfectly
framed this goodness look how it's
perfectly frame door closing it's gonna
stop this man man no [ __ ] this am/pm I'm
gonna take the whole [ __ ] out and he
does like a crazy 180 the beam does a
180 around his neck like an Olympic
sport I love how it looks like he barely
touches anything but the whole store
fell apart
dude he takes out the entire store like
it's perfectly lined up and there's no
dude you should have started slowing
down all right here like he didn't even
touch it even consider break it sleek
it's incredible how much damage you did
like he took out the case next to the
door he broke both doors and then like a
beam fell down look at out the amount of
catastrophe that's good yeah looks like
a Whole Foods or something right yeah
look at this it's all the people and
scooters it's like hey slow down after
you it's like if you let a kid drive a
car right
do you understand he didn't even slow
down after he hit the damn door yeah
like what is he thinking
boom I'm still going baby that's rad
it's crazy how that beam did like a 180
or on him it stayed balanced on him it's
amazing right
yeah watch this beam you see this beam
it rides him all the way through the
store and does it yes
[Laughter]
scooter logic so there you go and you
don't even dare tell me you're over
scooter videos because this [ __ ] is
funny all the way everyday people on the
streets are saying they love this good
or videos yeah
everyone the same yet everybody's
talking about scooter visit lucious you
guys know this artist he does like
gorilla spray painting he's very famous
very reputable probably the greatest art
living artist alive and he did a meme
I did an insta story where I had the
Joker snapchat and he was so inspired by
me that he dedicated a wall to me I love
it so shout out gosh six [ __ ] awesome
I found that I've had that effect on
several people throughout my life that
I'm so inspiring either you could attest
that uh I've heard it from people on the
streets
did he they're really good job I think
he's getting even better yeah this is I
really like a high level [ __ ] yeah but
it may if the Joker looked like me but
that'd be more or less scary if the
Joker had my body compared to Joaquin
Phoenix it would have no effect anything
because your body is totally normal
I think the Joker has to be like
starving
cuz he's like this anxious like if he's
fat like me because that applies you
have a good time at least you enjoy
eating he enjoys nothing I'm the penguin
if I'm a Batman yeah I'm the penguin
yeah I love the penguin too but the
Joker is my favorite Batman villain yeah
I haven't seen the joke you know is just
gonna say we should watch it maybe we
could see it um tonight maybe I want to
eat a joker movie review okay the in
cell uprising is here finally so lush
six is the man thank you to him
I guess this is it I guess we're at the
Trisha moment so I have a tap first of
all an apology video that I made I know
that apology videos is kind of Tricia's
then and so I wanted to take a stab at
it and I wanted to make my own apology
video inspired by her to her for her so
we'll go ahead and roll that now guys so
this is my apology video to Trisha
Paytas hey guys it's Ethan here again I
just wanted to come on really fast and
apologize to everybody I
totally did not expect the backlash from
our last video I wanted to basically
apologize to Trisha Paytas who is such a
sweet genuine person and I just really
like I wanted first of all apologize for
saying that she looked like she was at
an open-casket funeral like she was the
corpse inside of a casket that's not
true that's just not what I meant all
you're so beautiful you're such a queen
and I also wanted to apologize for
saying that you have like a 5 to 10 inch
and gorgeous [ __ ] that's bigger than my
dick I mean there I mean that's that
would basically make you a guy that
would basically mean you had a penis and
well I guess I'm kind of confused
because you said you're trans I don't
know I just I'm sorry cuz I don't want
to offend you I know that I'm sorry for
saying that you're not trans god man
even though you have like cup F jugs
that are always on display and not that
would make you I don't know but genders
all in the mind anyway and I shouldn't I
didn't even go there but mostly I just
want to apologize to Trisha and say that
I think she's really hot and it
definitely doesn't look like like oh she
definitely doesn't look like you know
she's she's been passed around as much
as a bowling ball and she's gone through
as much as a bowling ball to like she's
always hitting pins and being washed
back up and then people putting shoving
their fingers in her and then throw her
down the lane always AJ she comes back
and more fingers and throwing doesn't
lean doesn't look like that she's a
sweet she's hot and she's empowered
female well anyway guys I'm just really
apologetic and I hope y'all can forgive
me so with that being said let's uh
let's go ahead and start the podcast
thank you
please forgive me
so do you think that she was appreciated
that apology or that she'll be upset by
that apology I think that was very
touching right I teared up a couple of
times yeah I was getting emotional doing
it I was like wow that's super real like
the analogy of her being a bowling ball
image of a bowling ball in my head I
think of something to get around and
then the bowling ball came on my head
and you know it's it's a really special
analogy because when you think about the
pins as penises as well that she's being
thrown into just getting every hand with
penises wellhome she comes back fingers
jams in her head thrown down laying a
bunch of more penises and it's like when
does it stop and the ball comes back and
it's throwing us I got what does it stop
please
so hopefully she accepts my apology and
we can move past this she did ask for an
apology
I do hope that she accepts it and maybe
she'll still come on the podcast even
though she said she would never
reservation only erased her tweet or
something because I yeah oh man which
one did she erase so she she anyway I
said she she can come on the podcast if
she's man enough a joke to her here I
can I can actually show this she said
reacting h3 is video calling me nasty
she says the video is called h3 is worse
than Donald Trump Wow very political she
knows some people like him right okay
well whatever I said epic somebody said
you should have her on the podcast I
said if she's man enough she shouldn't
come on I thought that was pretty epic
she said 18 million dollars I'll do it I
said you'll definitely do it for free
she by the way
reached out to us first and then she
said apologize and then maybe she says
apologize for all your dumb ass trolling
so that's what I just did yeah
I want to bury the hatchet and I want
yeah I want to I want to bury the how do
you call those loca tops but they
the baby doll or something how do you
call those Oh like the stuff you sleep
in
that's baby doll what was she wearing
where her tits were like 75% oh I know I
remember when it's very the baby doll
yeah Perry the baby doll and I want to I
want to move on I want you on the
podcast and I just want to make amends
so and in spirit of that let's watch
let's enjoy her her response video
because she she made some claims here
that I think need to be addressed she
she said a lot of things about ela first
of all you know how we feel about that
she said things about dan which I can't
let slide personally you know I am very
entertaining so she just basically
washed my clip which is what I did with
Tiger belly the other day I found myself
just thinking to myself that's the very
thing though that's her main channel set
up I didn't realize this is our special
occasion set up so kitchen floor is man
channel that's the main course baby
living room floor is apology type videos
yeah got it and then like what's like
third channel yeah that's the garbage
you don't want to when you know the frit
when you see the fridge Brian or you
know it's good got it in general even if
they're boring are not really my flavor
I like podcasts because once bony [ __ ]
people talk because I'm alone all the
time this should be called thing in the
life of a loner because I'm always alone
so that's fine but just rambles on I'll
just skip to the I did timestamps then
we can kind of be more precise with this
30 minute idea
[ __ ] insane someone's at you but
can't keep my name out of your lips and
your mouth and yes you invited me on
your freaking podcast so I can't be of
that insane first of all you asked first
off do you want to come on you tweeted
at me publicly I seem to come on the
podcast so let's set that straight at
second of all me you being insane has
nothing to do with being in my mouth and
I know you yeah I mean yes in fact that
is a lot to do with being in my mouth I
mean you're in it you're entertaining
you're interesting you're entertaining
oh yeah baby
I don't call her baby she get the wrong
idea she's got a thesis that I want to
[ __ ] her I think but but I'm not much of
a bowler okay you're funny crazy you're
not like homeless crazy first of all we
need to start dating but she's beautiful
and pretty and and I apologize she loved
coming for you come for you on this
kitchen floor Eola very scared speak for
yourself don't dumb you just said I
can't make fun of you because you're
crazy you believe she doesn't cut or
anything she just puts it all out she
comes on it's gonna be such a great
episode that's why I know she's got to
come on she's gonna come on for free she
loves she likes the back-and-forth she
gets few she got something to talk about
it's great she loves it
those glasses are huge do I like the
glasses you do you could almost see her
ears in them they're so big like that's
a little wild
you don't mean like I can come for you
but I do about it for coming for you all
right come on let's say I got more time
stamps this she doesn't like go anywhere
she got 30 minutes of [ __ ] is ASA
here we go median time by the way median
tight aren't synonymous and roast beef
sandwich is not an synonymous with tight
I do okay does she put horsey sauce on
why'd you do that
she's funny I give her props it's funny
that's why we want her yeah I'm not I'm
not I've never said anything bad about
her everything has a positive spin
median it's like biting into an Arby's
roast beef sandwich without any curtains
off Oh without the beef curtains they
trim that easy how much before
delicious and I make my own mail she
makes her own yeah so there you gotta
answer I don't even know what that great
I think her vagina juices she makes her
own mail to lubricate the sandwich it's
pretty graphic
I'm too young for this conversation what
age is appropriate
you know you can see how much Russia
Lane that college I'm sure you have
already seen it I'm sure you've already
PO she thinks I've been to her website
because you're so concerned about my
genitals it may make me tea class she
erased it ma'am I wish you guys could
have seen the the comments cuz she
erased me like a Raceway she tweeted me
a close-up of her vagina yeah it was
gnarly bro ow
just like coughs I'm too fat don't fit
under the table
yeah I didn't know she would look up or
actually straight up pornographer like
she has a porn site where she does
everything you could think that a porn
scene does Nene vagina here she says I'm
worse than Donald Trump no no you smell
me you haven't seen me in person like
you nasty Donald Trump I don't why I'm
not really sure because he calls people
nasty I think that was the connection
you didn't invent calling people nasty
that's true but it's the best though too
why did she go straight turn mouth what
about the roast beef that you so
gloriously described their own man is
yeah what their own mayonnaise come on
well the rest of church is about healing
it's beautiful
it's nowhere near me your mouth we can
both happily say that we have no
interest in having sex with each other
well there you go I'm worse than Donald
Trump oh here she goes after ela now
this is when the gloves mask comes off
chime in she's so sweet and she's like
you're on the pack you don't chime in
you don't defend agree with what your
home says that's the only issue with her
is that there's no real opinion Wow
coming for her but it's not like it's
kind of like my issue with Spencer on
the impulse of podcasting there's no
there's no added opinion which is fine
people don't need to always give their
opinions just you do no [ __ ] what do you
think about that your response no
opinion oh I don't know well clearly she
doesn't read the comments cuz everybody
seems to think about her she'll watch
the podcast in my opinion she probably
just yes she doesn't get okay well she
goes on to say that she were her seed
Hasidic Jews she does she's not familiar
at all with her content at all but I
think it's ironic because I remember
even in that segment you spoke up in her
defense at one point you said she said
when she tweeted at me I knew you had a
tiny dick and you said and I was like
well I already said that dum-dum and
then you said well she's just saying
that I confirm what she already knew
yeah so she
you already did speak up a defense of
her tweet I did well she's making an
assumption that a lot of people do they
I don't know yeah I am more quiet than
like a normal co-host right so she's
expecting like loud I don't know she's a
loud person she's probably expecting
something like that from the co-hosts
but our friends know what we do here
it's not what we do here I think we got
our own style
well if Trish I want to find out she'll
come on the podcast she'll see what I
have to say oh [ __ ] damn that's right
yeah dude we're talking about Trisha how
dare you
well I think it's just evidence that she
hasn't watched about tests yeah she goes
on to say that I railroad you out into
submission so here we go Railroad ela
into submission
can you let me talk you male
chauvinistic Pig ass [ __ ] just my
husband's on that I didn't say that she
says were confident clothes [ __ ] and I
mean she's trans I really is a guy who
people have always thought you're trans
you're so transparent entrance both and
so maybe that explains could you were
saying you you identify a fob which will
see what I'm saying this is like
reaction inception or so and I think but
I feel like she talked boy yeah that I
guess does she say anything about this I
don't remember I don't know I was
sleeping when I did this sorry Tricia
just not interesting enough I was
literally sleeping when I did this I
don't know how I did this I was on night
quo because I'm sick mm-hmm
and I was like I knew that I couldn't
watch this video flat cuz it's just so
dull and so I know I had to do two
timestamps and I I mean you you were
next to me I sorry you were like
following a slave
Regina taking time Stan's writing stuff
in there fine what's going on here
that's some interest but I actually like
the stuff you did we're making sense I
know I'm I only needed 10% of my brain
to watch your video Trish maybe even
less I don't know how what percent I'm
using right now but I'll tell you it's
not 100 uh I don't I don't know
understand my note on this can't make on
people you can't look at that be like
that's a female like she looks like a
frickin open bro you can be in a casket
and a female you know I'm saying you can
be a cadaver and have tits yeah it's
like an overall in generic judgment that
you just can't make them people you
can't look at that be like that's a
female
oh you I've been like she looks like a
frickin open casket like what is it do I
look like a hot female or do I look like
African open yeah all I can say hot we
just she's what wears one this shot was
crazy I just said your cleavage is odd I
didn't say it was hot trust me that's
not what I meant that's not what I said
you know I'm sure there are cadavers
there are bodies with big tits just
because that's how they died with big
debts I mean I love how she tries to be
here that ambassador for transgender
people and they don't want her she made
the dumbest statements when she was like
I'm transgender
yeah was that an opinion you know how
dare I
okay so don't know ela please don't talk
over me let's move on
you're ruining the show gila oh yeah
this is great
you'll like this I'll let you respond to
this point she says cleavage this isn't
Israel she says she thinks that's so
crazy
does she know that you're from Israel
she's just trying to mock your yeah
birth country but you know that you
don't have to cover you don't you know
you'd have to cover yourself in Israel
right doesn't appear so that's great
yeah
yeah well Trisha here's a PSA you can
wear your tits like that in Israel yeah
and that would be totally fine if you
want you can do everything you can do
here mother it's not a yeah it's not yes
exactly
thank you Lila it's not a yes that's
very normal it's a comfortable women are
allowed to show their cleavage here by
the way that's not a normal amount of
cleavage that's like basically every
knows everything am I wrong you guys
know it's a lot of it's a lot of tit
right Ian and Zach yeah Zach yeah Zach I
mean yeah we've we've all voted
unanimously that's a good amount of time
I mean I could see maybe someone in like
the Walmart like trashy Walmart people
subreddit going around with that money
so much cleavage
maybe females around you don't show
cleavage and that's cool
no no shaming those who like to be
conservative no conservative shaming
here but like show no my did your mayor
makeup I slept in that
is comfortable like show bra you did a
video though anyway that's that yeah and
then she goes on to say she loves when
people call her dumb you know long yeah
let's just watch all these I'm just go
to their City choose moment just easy in
salt I mean okay that doesn't offend me
because like I know I'm not done
obviously I mean being like chubby is a
little bit of a trigger I want to call
her fat I never called her fat what did
I ever call her fat did I ever call
Trisha Paytas fat or jelly beached whale
at some point was that her someone else
think of it someone else has just been
so many it's hard to remember I would
never call Trisha Paytas a beached whale
not sure about that I never and my whole
life would call Trisha Paytas a swollen
Twinkie I don't know I wouldn't say it
about her I never called her dumb either
I call I said if she ate a one stick of
deodorant
she's like one stick of viateur away
from having the IQ of shoenice ten IQ
points is a lot that's a big difference
an intellectual capacity here she says
let's just skip to the Hasidic Jew
comment you like the whole you know when
the hoax
I wake up over it yeah you know when
when the Hulk tells the secret he goes
you want to know my secret I'm always
angry yeah eel is always over it to
where they have that relationship well I
don't think so anyway they seem a
conservative I believe they're Hasidic
Jewish people and I'm trying to be a
serve it up let's see which is fine
Jewish men love Jewish people like I'm
obsessed she goes I love how she goes
I'm obsessed with Jewish people what I
don't like that she's obsessed with
Jewish people you know you know who's
obsessed with Jewish people Adolf Hitler
but okay she thinks that we're Hasidic
Jews based on what we're wearing
conservative has sit here Hasidic Jews
let me show you what Hasidic Jews look
like there you go just just the testing
of yet
her Israel trivia here these are my
people
look good they [ __ ] and also Hasidic
women wear wigs
by the way mm-hmm look at these guys
such gangsters his seeds stink like
mother dude oh yeah they wear this all
year round
why dude there's the greasiest looking
people ever they don't shave they don't
shower they all got these gnarly suits
bro that hat is out of control you look
like a lamp imagine wearing this in like
a hundred degree weather day yeah it's
really summer 90% you who made it tea
mmm yeah the seeds this I'm Marissa dick
bro there's me at my bar mitzvah I had
the Jew curl and everything look at this
that's at home baby
anyway thought that was funny and in
summary she says she does want to come
on the podcast forgetting that you were
the one that started in open casket
funeral she would rather shield the day
she does the podcast as they shall suck
my deck now she said that she'll come on
ela if I apologize which I did already
do so do I
having permission do I have your
permission to hot to receive fellatio
from Trisha Paytas no I'm just why I
don't know where I'm going with that
well she keeps bringing it up even
though we never make that comments
I never expressed interest in her we
just like you for who you are Trisha
we're oh you need any sexual favor
you're more than a sexual object to me
don't you understand that's why I think
like all these comments about beached
whale open casket funeral these are not
sexual objects these are objects that
have value and love in this world like
have you ever seen what happens when a
beach one of whale beaches how many
people come out and try to save the
whale and bring it back to the ocean
like that's all I'll I still can't
remember if it was hard that you called
that yeah I don't remember I don't think
I called her Beach well maybe it's
somewhere else and they it may have been
her though let's be honest I put a
screen shot are you here to expose me
but my analogy is really what is the
conclusion from your guyses well you
didn't use the word whale but you made a
joke
well you had a song inside Oh I said you
washed up on the beach it doesn't work
by the way for some reason I said it
looks like she washed up on the beach
right well that does that doesn't say
anything about fat that is not charity
compose yeah I believe yeah she just
looks decomposed I'd say but but if I
did say she was a beached whale which I
never would that's a beautiful
compliment because a lot of people care
about beached whales and the same with
the open casket funeral what's wrong
with that everybody comes and honors you
at your funeral there's love and beauty
and peace and definitely nothing sexual
about either those images Trisha so all
you bringing up about me fellatio and
all this I just want to come here and
talk to you I want to talk I want to
talk shop and have a good time and just
you know that's it well we'll see we'll
see if she's willing to come on now well
I made my peace
like you literally put me in the title
and the thumbnail so why are we feeding
the troll' dan whoever you are dan who
would be a no Dan why you see the troll
because you put it as the title the
thumbnail oh you make bo3 videos about
me not having only made two videos about
you I wasn't responding the final one
another like I'm so over it so over it's
like kinda like this week I'm still over
I'm choosy there's anything else to say
man I'm over it I want to keep this
going for as long as possible we got I
am over it
wait do we really yeah it's pretty okay
yes I'm so sorry to interrupt we got
yeah dan I guess Dan is over you Trisha
Dan just no new you Dan doesn't like
Trisha apparently he wrote she knows
some really harsh things about her it's
not that I don't like her it's I don't
care would you what would you rate her
on a scale of one to ten in terms of
attraction be honest I don't know for a
400 dan is mildly attracted to her
honestly back again what would you rate
her on one to ten ahead come on
all right you dumped yeah let's go to
break they're all afraid of the girls
yeah he's gonna come in one day and
they're gonna have to meet her
face-to-face do you got you guys should
be scared of her I feel like she's gonna
strangle me when she comes in here
you're gonna have to get security
I'll be your security the silent Israeli
make sure to cover your shoulders though
and don't talk over me you know how it
is like an Israeli law privacy calm is
the place that you need to go to protect
your identity online you use your credit
card for reoccurring payments you use it
to buy stuff on PayPal you even use it
to buy furry suits and weird hentai porn
from Asia but you don't want to use a
real credit card when you do that
absolutely not that's where privacy calm
comes in they give you the ability to
make these virtual credit cards that are
tied directly to your bank account so
that you can purchase play things and
that you
with your credit card without any risk
of identity being stolen or reoccurring
payments being joking you out of
existence
yeah there's no issues there's no
problems at all look for example I just
go new card which I already made here
it's easy to do
Ethan's Amazon card there you go Bob's
your uncle here I'm going to use it on
I'm gonna show you guys how easy it is
to use on Amazon I already got the
plug-in installed so all I do is click
that
here it is Ethan's Amazon card it's a
real card use this frickin right there
boom there's no problem there's no risk
it's privacy calm and here he gets even
better with privacy head to privacy calm
/ h3 and you all are gonna get five
dollars free on your first purchase for
a limited time only guys that's five
dollars for free that's literally free
money go to privacy calm / h3 and sign
up now you are gonna love the privacy
the ease of mind and you're gonna love
that five $40 plate
there's plenty of Daisy look where you
just want the food you don't want to
cook you don't want to go anywhere
you're over it all it's been a long day
or you just want to treat yourself I
don't need to explain any further all I
need to tell you is that door - connects
you to your favorite restaurants in your
city they make ordering easy you open
the door - app you choose what you want
to eat and your food will be delivered
to you wherever you are
ela not only is your favorite pizza
joint already on door - but there are
340 thousand restaurants at 3300 cities
and you might just find a new favorite -
ela okay and with door-to-door delivery
in all 50 states and canada canada the
51st state
aka order from your local go to Zoar
choose from your favorite national
favorites like Chipotle Wendy's
chick-fil-a and the Cheesecake Factory
ela don't worry about dinner let dinner
come to you with door - but here we go
let's get interesting right now our
listeners could get five dollars off
their first order of 15 dollars or more
when you download the door - app and
enter promo code h3 that's five dollars
for free off your first order of 15
dollars or more when you download the
door - app from the App Store and enter
code h3 so don't forget that's promo
code HD for five dollars off your first
order from door - ela ela
like death mailing things is something
we all have to deal with eventually and
that's where stamps.com comes in we
don't have time as human beings in this
fast-paced life to go to the post office
you got a park you got traffic you've
got to lug your package it's ridiculous
that's why we need a futuristic solution
that's that's good for everybody stamps
calm the most popular time-saving tool
for small businesses and individual
stamps calm eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts you couldn't even get at the
post office if you went there Wow Sam
Cellcom brings all the amazing services
of the US Post Office right to your
computer whether your small office
sending invoices or an online sellers
shipping our products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of package a
day Sam comp can handle it with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready you just hand it to your mail
courier or drop it in a mailbox it is
that simple with stamps I'll come you
get five cents off every first class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
not to mention a fraction of the cost of
those expensive postage meters I don't
know what a postage meter is but I'm
assuming somebody out there does Sam
Cellcom is a no-brainer saving you time
and money it's a no wonder that 700,000
small businesses are already using
stamps calm right now our listeners get
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment Wow they have truly lost
their minds over at stamps comm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in h3 that stamps comm
enter h3
welcome to the Ethan is late from the
bathroom episode that's all I got now we
just wait silently we're live even we're
alive and we're bored sitting here five
minutes there's like a fan outside I
don't know if he's a fan but he was I
hate it and I was like a dude and I
walked the [ __ ] door on him but he
was looks like he was waiting for
another office but I don't know he
looked kind of suspicious how long you
been life just a few seconds not that
bad yo so we talked about Trisha that
was exciting
oh there was a write in from a fan a
trans fan who wanted to finally close
the book on this hole at Trisha being
trans thing so I'm gonna read this now
they said uh-huh oh god my throat is so
[ __ ]
I take a little sip of water does it
sound [ __ ] up yeah the horse remember
how we did dead air last episode she'd
do that again
mm-hmm cuz we only did it for like 20
seconds yeah because I always ask him I
couldn't even ask cuz that ruined it but
I was wondering if you if we can't laugh
there's no like a laugh no in a contest
you can't laugh okay just silence the
thing about dead air is that the
audience needs to be confused they need
to know is anyone even there that's dead
air okay I'm ready whenever you are sure
you won't do a dead air off do we want
to finish this I'm fittin read this
email first yeah okay no let's just do
it now we've already set it up okay okay
here we go
Ian's life switching was was making me
laugh you're broke
cuz he keeps with me and you and the
lights game good I don't know to long I
started to feel bad did you start to
feel bad no I was getting into it
love to do a whole episode just perform
we gotta do one wait everyone okay hey
guys I love the recent podcast and I
just wanted to give some hair here's a
hidden message to Trisha Trisha of you
are actually family washes they just say
Ethan said methi
vagina flops hey Trish is not really
trans in and then the timestamp that I
said it and you told me that and I'll
apologize for everything I ever said to
you cuz you are true fan of the show
alright glad I got that of the way hi
guys I love the recent podcast just want
to get my input on a Trisha topic some
background my trans male who's been out
for about four to five years and I'll be
medically transitioning soon a lot of
the stuff she was explaining is just
regular stuff women go through like ela
said Trisha was just talking about not
dressing overly feminine and wanting to
lay low with makeup and not want it to
be sexualized by men which is funny
considering her content you just got
slammed the majority of women feel that
way exactly
Trisha mentions no feelings or gender
dysmorphia which is the medical edition
that identifies someone who is
transgender if she were to go to a
gender identity therapist and asked who
medically transition she would most
likely be tonight because she has no
gender dysmorphia she also mentions a
weird fixation with Gaiman and the past
she has been obsessed with game in which
many find weird this doesn't make her
transgender either it just means she's
fetishizing homosexuals like a weirdo
very well stated her explanation of
being transgender is wildly and correct
and she should not be considered a
representative of the transgender
community at all well yeah good point it
hurts me to see Trisha talking about
choosing your gender when you cannot in
fact choose it your gender is with you
since you're born it cannot be supposed
to change the reasons transgender people
are transgenders because the gender
doesn't match their sex if I could
change my gender to female to match my
my few
sex organs I would do it in a heartbeat
because I would no longer have gender
dysmorphia just for ya oh I'm sorry
dis for you my bad it makes me angry to
see her inserting herself into a group
of people who struggle with this medical
condition and the same time get clowned
out by transforming people she has no
idea what being transgender is like
she's insane bro
this was hella long but I hope it gave
you some insight on the situation keep
it up and I look forward to it and I got
a group from Grayson a super trooper
that was actually a really insightful
explanation agree yeah exactly
I've never seen her actually describe
anything like that like feeling that her
gender doesn't match her sex yeah which
is what trans yeah but then again you
know like she like Grace had pointed out
dude you just have a fetish for gay men
that's just a weird thing about you
she's obsessed with Jews and you're
obsessed with Jews can we talk about
that that's the strangest thing I ever
know that's the weirdest thing I can
know about anybody I'm jus obsessed hi
I'm Trisha Paytas I'm a vertigo I'm a
Virgo
I like walks on the beach and I'm jus
obsessed oh [ __ ] put that on your tinder
profile okay let's get to the bottom of
this now a lot of you guys have been
wanting a conclusion to the bachelor
with Ian yes I'm sorry back here I don't
think we're gonna have that conclusion
we were slated to record it tomorrow now
we had a big argument argument about
this in the last episode and the third
girl the the wild card does not want to
come on the show is that right in
that's what's been expressed to me yes
and and why is that why is it not on the
screen because I told you we need then
to have I see Dan just eating chips all
I see is Dan eating chips and I want to
say yeah
yeah show yourself when you talk here go
ahead why she don't want to be on the
show dad almost looked like that gay for
dating popcorn like watching the drama
okay you know just not everyone wants to
be on camera wants to be a big spectacle
you know ah you already told me the
reason why you play hard-to-get are you
only the reason that she doesn't want to
be she doesn't want him to think that
she just wants to be on the show that's
that's why we're very specific we
already talked about this and now you're
telling me what I think right yeah it's
both let's just keep it low energy no
there's no low energy here on this topic
but I feel like every time I bring in on
and we have a conversation about
something I'm like okay let's talk about
on the show it's always like oh she just
not everyone wants to be on the camera
that not always said there's more
information than that not everything we
say has to be a big okay my problem is
the third girl because she found you
through the show she knows exactly what
we're doing here she can't play that
innocent she knows exactly about the
bachelor with the three what we do here
she decided to you know talk to you see
what's up
now she ruined it for the other two
girls the game and she won't come on on
the show at least say hi what's up here
I'm the girl that ruined it why would
she want to do that you guys have
demonized hurry she's not
go ahead Zach no I agree with ela I
think she totally [ __ ] this up that me
what did you say in I said I don't want
to hear from Zach on this what does that
mean
what are you talking about what is that
what is that this is low energy we all
are good positive but not happy and that
caused a lot of a lot of game I'm not
quite sure what what what his advice is
invalid him wait can you you have to
expand on that please just I don't want
to hear from Zach he doesn't know cuz he
hasn't he's not on the camera with this
he's not having his dating life put all
over that alright that okay that's fair
that is very fair like say we just start
yelling at you because your girlfriend
didn't want to come on the show like is
that very valid no he done now
hold on hold on but then again I am in a
relationship with my girlfriend stop
stop why am I on the camera having a
conversation thank you I committed
devoted relationship this is someone
you're talking then we have to fix this
you have to have like an override switch
er you know what I mean yeah okay
alright go ahead so don't okay I feel
like that's completely different because
you're you're dating correct you're not
in a relationship I'm not dating anyone
yeah okay well for the sake of the show
I feel like it's been completely messed
up yes the integrity is gone and I think
we're gonna have to call it so I think
we had it we didn't fully establish so I
wasn't supposed to go on any dates or
talk to any girls as long as this was
ongoing that's you know okay if or those
girls like I wouldn't be upset if either
of these contestants were date going on
dates right now because this is so
strong out okay let me let me tell you
if you found a girlfriend that became
serious I would expect you to tell us
and then we would call it off your
happen okay but you have a third girl
who you're more interested in you've
been talking to you had like a few hours
conversation but I feel like if she was
in this if she was you've talked to her
on the phone in if she was in this
competition with the other two girls you
would choose this third girl Brooke
right around
just go ahead tell the truth I don't get
I'm not that's irrelevant though because
why that's not part of the show but she
but she she came to you through the show
no she came to me through my dance if
she came through the show we miss but
where did you [ __ ] where how did she
find out about you she is aware of the
show actually find out you're single she
didn't she mention the dating how'd she
find out you're single she on the show
look at the end of the day you got a you
know give back to the poppin mama
Ethan Aniela and that's what it's all
about you have to respect and say thank
you
he's right no I actually I feel for the
other girls first of all I wouldn't now
bring them here for a pointless date it
doesn't sound well I don't know if he's
in love but it's more interested it
sounds like in the third girl and one of
the other girls so she does want to come
out that's a whole new thing I guess it
that was the one you were taught Ian
start talking his girl apparently she's
like I don't even come out anymore after
talking to him right hand I mean it
didn't play out exactly like that well I
don't know what I got I don't feel that
it's so and all the for the viewers I
mean we're not just making like fake
content there needs to be some realness
to it well yeah and in goes so he goes
well it's just content isn't it and I
say no first of all how dare you I don't
know what show you're trying to emulate
but that's how they all operate
no but the pretense is that they're
there for do you know normal way too
many people do you know that there's
like at least three or four couples from
the bachelor and bachelorette that are
still happily married to this day that's
not even including the bachelor in
paradise couples that got married and
had kids it's not is it's about finding
true love with the third girl but she
won't even come say hi I'm calling it
off I'm calling it off I said okay well
why don't you just let's just claim this
third girl the winner
bring her out and record it for the show
see that's where you know everyone's
being a camera I respect that I don't
know you know I was all excited I wrote
a flamenco guitar piece thank you Dad
yeah oh my god see so what I'm thinking
of doing is that I want you to have a
date now I'm doing me an email of a date
and Zach will serenade us I'll probably
be more romantic anyway I'm gonna
fingers [ __ ] you're not on board with
this no well said what do you what do
you want to do you want to do go through
with it with these two girls that claim
a winner especially when we know that
one of them doesn't want to come now so
what am I supposed to do on our planned
segment Ian I mean I don't know with
welcome that didn't even want to come
that kind of botched it anyway with only
two what happened wasn't working can you
describe what happened with the girl
that didn't want to come I think they
just felt a little uncomfortable to be
flown around the world for this and
you're talking getting honeymoon suites
and stuff for people that have never
even fantasy suite in now imagine can
you see why that that might make her was
weird to be I mean our intentions were
were made quite clear lone around the
globe and said here is a honeymoon suite
for this person who us for the show but
Ian you're a catch any girl would be
lucky today yes did I claim Zach the
winner can we go I got the hair for it
apparently you don't need our permission
in I don't by the way Ian I'm not I'm
not forcing anyone just bunk with you I
mean that's how rageous that's what you
said on the flyer out we'll get her a
hotel room and you I'm kidding I'm not
forcing I want to stay in a room with
you so these are things that we should
have made clear oh wait that's what
that's all she knows okay guys watch the
show Dan for more details yeah the one
who's organizing the event
not you any girl would be lucky to come
out here and date you thank you sir
don't put yourself down like that Thank
You Zack do I have any roses for you
Zack I think there's one in the fridge
yeah what do we do about this yeah this
whole thing is a disaster at this point
it's a disaster that's a disaster I know
do we just move on to season two doesn't
want to participate in this [ __ ] maybe
this was just a pilot season and we
don't even call it tomorrow this is the
pilot well if this is the pilot the
networks definitely not picking it up
here's the next bachelor bachelorette
should we unveil the next back I also
feel like I saw people in the comments
saying I'm ungrateful for that for what
for I don't know going on a date for the
opportunity Leah but since day one
I was never stoked I said I was single
and then you guys said yeah you have to
approve of all day they do falling
tripping over their feet running to you
you've got women all around the globe
sour points for you before calling you
an insult you already moved into the new
PDF you wanna be celibate to be an Enzo
you went against the family that's the
part that's hard about this exactly you
want to get daddy what do you glad you
answer that charge Ian you sad those
Google shits and you just moved on
you went against the family no I did I
think you guys are making it worse than
it is I was down to keep going and then
you guys you know because we're not fake
Ian I don't know I feel like this their
girl threw a wrench in it okay I'd like
to think that that you being the model
employee that you are a member of this
family as Zack said you would say to me
in a perfect world you would say a third
girl approached me she learned about me
on the show I like her a lot to be
talking to her I think that we need to
end the end up so say I met a girl that
wasn't then I don't know over the last
two months and I I have to disclose that
to you no that's a little different no
you don't have to disclose that I don't
see how that's different
emori moody [ __ ] stupid she came to
you through the show what's the
difference
no you're not stupid you're playing dumb
right ela he turn off his mic bad air
goes out bad air put it back on dan he's
in charge of his own destiny now Ian I
didn't mean to call you stupid I meant
you're playing stupid okay there's a
difference between a girl who found you
through the show and a girl you randomly
met unassociated I'm just saying we were
at Disney having a good time and I said
oh I kind of been talking to scroll
little she's pretty cool and I thought
you'd be like oh that's nice and then
it's become like a huge awful thing
she's called me and she's like I felt a
little uncomfortable about that I'm
feeling weird and I don't know she's not
happy with these kind of conversations I
don't think so is it souring her
experience of being a fan of the show no
but we could just talk about the adults
Awards if you want to do that instead
you want to come in here is that what
you mean yeah okay come in here okay I
love you in I shouldn't have called him
stupid that was rude that's not what I
meant
not cool I agree that was that's not
what I meant I meant to say you're
playing stupid you wanna get on the
kitchen floor yeah I owe my paw at it
apology Ian I apologize for calling you
stupid that's not what I meant to say I
blurted it out and I and I and is
actually very very intelligent he's very
sweet there wouldn't be the first time
people have called me dumb that's not
what I meant
I should I apologize that just that was
wrong with me it's okay and you're
catchy thank you Thank You Zach but but
you do acknowledge that I mean you can
see the difference between what I meant
is like it should be obvious the
difference between I think we just
really the show and not to the show I
think we just didn't get all the ground
rules at the show that we probably
should I guess we need a lawyer here
yeah we need someone in our greater
yeah well we've been through a lot these
past 20 minutes and I feel like I
snapped a little bit there when I called
you stupid
I'm it's fine I'm all right and you know
it didn't take a lot for you to do that
I'm low-energy because I'm sick I'm
Sarah I'm low-energy but I just I just
feel so bad I gotta put on that bra and
apologize on the kitchen floor do this I
would be nice but yes I was serious
about feeling your [ __ ] though I know
good well Ian is here to present to us
Ian was lucky enough to attend the
pornhub Awards this year yes I did that
to come about someone reached out to us
extended the invite to all of us the two
bet in the back didn't really weren't
feeling it and you guys it was kind of
last minute so I don't know yeah you
know I mean I would prefer to send a
correspondent yeah so uh I told her yeah
sure I'll definitely go I got a plus-one
so a friend of mine came with me and it
was it was a lot of fun it was really
cool so first of all I'm interested in
both Dan and Zach denied to go on the
grounds that they did want to offend
their girlfriend which I thought was
interesting oh I think that they thought
it was disrespectful to the girlfriend I
mean I appreciate how how classic they
are but if it's for work I feel like
they should get it past I'm not giving
it people more [ __ ] today
I'm leaving everyone alone for the rest
of the day forget I brought it there I
feel like I got a cha big to issue with
yeah chill out I'm sorry everyone I'm
just trying to entertain everybody here
so this is the pamphlet very nice it's a
high-quality uh so tell me about the
porno Awards though did you walk the red
carpet so they gave me the wrong ticket
they gave me a general admission ticket
and they had said I'd be lean impress so
we had to sneak in to the red carpet
which wasn't too bad I just kind of
pulled a random email up and went Oh as
you can see here
I have to be in there oh good job person
was kind of like what do you need to do
and I'm like I just need to take some
photos and she was like okay I would do
that twice Wow good job one night cuz I
got kicked out again once you get kicked
out well like then I they moved everyone
upstairs who only had this ticket and
then I had to get back in so my friend
kind of distracted the security guard
and I just like oh my god
snuck in good job they didn't work but
we have a lot of fans in the oh really
in the community anyone notable say I do
I wasn't familiar with them but six
different people all came up no way yeah
we have pictures yeah got a cup now
these uh Monsieur where's the pores and
Belle Delphine was nominated for one yes
she was nominated for best celebrity so
apparently that categories decided based
on searches on pornhub
yeah Oh interesting so that's why a lot
of the names on pornhub yeah that's
weird
so Belle is crushing it on the library a
lot of those people don't do porn yeah
Kim Kardashian was nominated eople are
just searching her name yeah oh that's
funny um Bella Thorne was nominated she
won the visionary award not quite sure
what her vision is she directed this
like short film that was pornographic oh
really
yeah did they show it they showed like a
couple clips of it no when they show
stuff on the screen do they show like it
going in you know or they just like well
op list what about when they presented
the award for backdoor beauty top anal
performer today something like that no
anal what about what about the category
as top bbw what do you see or you know
doing see a whole lot on that one either
they buried the lede a little bit what
about the splash zone top squirting
performer yes I thought I saw no splash
no splash so they didn't show any
hardware form No did you see any titties
on the on the screen yeah but they were
dressed yeah which as last year a lot of
people were naked but the venue got they
moved to like a lot nicer venue and I
think no nudity I think someone had said
you have to work the email I got dress
code was like please no nudity mmm I
think the venue required that it's like
the walls could talk what are they
afraid of like having some titties in
their will will lower the real-estate
value what about the category all at the
same damn time
top double penetration performer I
didn't see any double doubles going on
highly experienced top milf performer
yeah of course yeah and they had a lot
of musical guests a lot of cool artists
performed and it was actually a lot of
fun it was cool I can't find that album
damn I don't know if I have a time stamp
to it here in my document if you could
just send it on this court but at any
rate um so you so tell me about the
process you ran into so funny thing
about running into Belle Delphine is
that you were wearing the I own Belle
Delphine hat yeah this one here I put on
cuz well I didn't think she was gonna be
there I knew she was nominated but you
didn't yeah it she would fly there from
England so I figured I just wear and to
represent right and then we were sitting
up in the balcony and they said Belle
Delphine won the award during like a
break when they were setting up one of
the stages and they went she's here in
the audience uh what they did they
didn't present it to her so then my
friend actually spotted her in the front
row and he was like is that that girl
that you mentioned she's dressed as a
Grim Reaper she was like big scythe and
her coat said like I eat children or
something it was very sexy very
elaborate costume she had very easy to
spot and she had her pink hair and all
that and so the moment the show ended I
was like we got a run down because you
guys were like you got to go find bet
long yeah put a lot of pressure on you
yeah I found out he was there why not
believe that she was there I was
actually excited we were get we just got
done giving
oh [ __ ] but he I mean it sounds like he
really put it all into this you see
through security you went through there
you caught bail so yeah so I ran down
there my friend distracted the security
guard I got inside and then it kind of
ran up to her and I was like bail and
she looked and she was kind of like hi
how you doing kind of like okay and then
I just pointed at my hat yeah and then
she saw it and was like holy [ __ ] where
where did that come from and I told her
and she was like freaking out about it I
was like there's like this is the Hat I
was like yep that jar right over there
and so she was you know very stoked on
that that's so awesome and she was so
nice really cool person about that
that's really cool so you said that she
didn't accept her award like most people
will go up to the stage and accept it
right yeah she didn't they did a bunch
of awards that weren't on the camera
that they showed so they were kind of
like while they were setting up Oh Belle
Delphine won best uh you know kind of
told everyone
that's celebrity so that's interesting
so she wanna know but she doesn't have
actually porn on pornhub right she just
did those trolls
yeah those 12 years old people she she
had enough people searching for her from
that yeah that she won the award for
best celebrity yeah I believe that's how
it was picked you and so you didn't see
any tats you didn't see any sexual
activity no you didn't see anything
interesting I did go in the bathroom
upstairs and there's a photo of that but
you probably can't show it but yeah can
you send me the dang all the album I did
I don't see it in this card it's in this
court or any are these all safety show
because I know some of them had a lot of
tittie in it well we can kind of hide
the screen and then here let me see let
me uh how come there's no videos in this
right there's only one video of an
acceptance speech for best squirter oh
you wanted it what's the reason you
captured that one and I just thought it
was funny because she said she just
thinks like a guy named Mike probably
who makes her squirt you know that's
what she said
I think just number three yeah that's
when I race yeah like that
okay here we go so here we go Ian's
journey through the pornhub award what
was the deleted one yes okay yeah so
here's Ian and ablaze me on the scene
man great outfit Wow I was gonna really
goof it up like I was gonna get out like
a fake mustache and like big aviators
and a Hawaiian shirt but then like five
minutes before leaving my friend was
like he was like some things came
together and I'm looking kind of fly and
he came in a suit he was gonna do it
with me and then I was like well no I
don't want to actually look good yeah me
me and I was like well I think this is
way better this is pretty good yeah so I
was like well shoot and then I had to
change quick but you know this makes the
Hat so tell me if these people oh here
you go
yeah so that was the carpet and you're
upstairs oh so these are fans that came
up oh so these are both pornographer so
the one on the right is the one on the
left
I don't believe so sheet that's just her
boyfriend by IG there are a couple
people that if you can cycle through
these are all fans all fans will all
work in the industry I wrote down some
of their names already Elyse Kyle hi May
and Chloe and her tail yeah so shout out
to all you guys he's got a cocktail in
your hand what's that you're holding yes
drink you know you were making fun of
the venue for doing like no nudity but I
think it makes it a little classier yeah
yeah it does but it's kind of words but
I think it's kind of cool to make it
like a classy mm-hmm fairly stated and
also we won't be able to show any of
this right at the same time - yeah
totally
so yeah it was super classy the it was
well what the [ __ ] is this oh yeah tell
me about that one so I went okay it's
just a sink it's a bathroom sink with
blood covered in blood I went in the
back so tell me about that I just walked
in there and it was just empty but those
blood everywhere cut from cocaine use I
was thinking like putting on you know
the nosebleeds in the nosebleed section
what do we see here so this is just this
was my view this is a animal age look
like it's a nice stage yeah it looks
great yes so that was the host um asa
akira who's that she's kind of oh she's
like Japanese yeah I know her she's just
Bobby show a lot yeah so she was the
host and she did a good job
the the puns were out of control and the
whole thing every I'm like wondering how
you write for a show like that because
it was a lot of jokes it would be like
here's the top performer and I really
mean top you know like horny you know
like that like non-stop so Bella Thorne
so that was accept her award yeah so
they were really hyping up her movie
wasn't good for her
Rogers what did browsers mind what
didn't they want yeah they wanna I think
just best best oh top channel they beat
out Black's oh yeah I have a hard time
believing black to beat hey they won the
that the what's-his-name Weinstein they
won the Harvey Weinstein award well he's
a big producer and they pride and you
know Pro I would imagine the peruses
they're probably [ __ ] some of the girls
I don't know if I'm making everyone seen
warrant let's move on so here's Danica
Warrior little speech for really good
orientation they're young well done
[Music]
the tux burger op squared
congratulations there Steve
just congratulations thank you to good
jobs and thank you to Steve especially
is that everything was more so here I
think you smell how close realtor I
wasn't close enough for smell you can
smell it from that distance I was a
little sick so you know maybe I'm asking
for all the people watching who are says
was there how did she look up close she
looked I mean pretty similar she looks
the same yeah you know I could see her
her wig and stuff that she's rocking not
natural curls but yeah what was she
wearing is she wearing lingerie I can't
tell I think maybe under it
yeah and then the big cloak she had that
she was wrapping this big cloak it's
pretty bad everyone was really excited
to see her like as I was right after
this
Riley read-write came up and was like
sorry to interrupt your guys
conversation but I just was wondering if
I could get a photo with a bell and and
I don't have like a halt she was very
gracious she took posed with a bunch of
people but he seemed to be very big hit
there oh yeah she's dude she's I don't
know that I mean I don't know much about
what she's done but I don't think she's
ever gone out in public like this
he's very mysterious that's all I was
taken aback by you know how how open and
she was very sweet
yeah I'm surprised there's not more
video I know you had an idea for a
sketch to like ask interview porn stars
and asking what they thought about the
Kurdish situation whatever happened with
that I guess didn't really get the
access you didn't have the access man
yeah so this is afterwards you went and
chased her down yeah so I was in an area
was a realist style access yeah I was
really like Michael Moore in there
charging people and you know did you ask
her any specific questions did you get
to the bottom I asked her um I told her
that we'd love to have her on obviously
thank you very good
clearly undid that direct I asked her
did you really get arrested and she was
like I can't speak on that yeah
they're enough you know I don't remember
anything else
just a couple rapid-fire things I said
you guys obviously would love love to
have her yeah she was wondering where
you guys were yes well so not there
unfortunately have a baby yeah yeah I
can't bring the baby I don't think I
feel like I feel like in a parallel
universe we could have gone to that I
don't mind going to this event yeah it
was fun in the maze it was great a
parallel universe where we didn't have a
it was all comes what I mean well
because we don't know anything
yeah not with that we would just have to
plan for it and this was all kind of
very last minute yeah now it's all like
we need to coordinate who's watching
theater or watch day uh who's got the
dogs
well 2020 pornhub exactly this picture
is this is yeah I'm so glad I found her
yeah I was worried I'd missed her I was
like waiting for a while everyone was
leaving the security was kicking people
out jake paul sprinted by oh my god what
the hell and him and that guy from
impulsive like Logan's sidekick yeah and
they looked all like frantic and crazy
he's probably hit a lot in the bathroom
yeah I think Tina was Tanner she was
nominated for something yeah I think she
was no mood for best top top celebrity
that's that's amazing that Belle won
even without having like actually
anything on pornhub except those gags
yeah well what does Tana have important
people are searching tannaz name so yeah
and then at the very i'd been in there
and i was about to leave and then she
finally came off yes so glad you know
who you were no no that breaks my heart
no idea we're following it all alive as
ian was updating and it was very
exciting I think she would even be there
and there yeah she's there well I and I
asked I was like I'm really surprised
you were here and she said that it was
kind of very last-minute opportunity and
then she took him up on it and then she
was leaving back to England like the
next day so she kind of came in
knew the word so it worked out well
that's disappointing she didn't know who
you were cuz I always assumed she was a
super fan a super fan yes I guess it
means she's just been watching get her
part you know of the podcast mm-hmm you
gotta know who in the Internet well in
we were just so good out we were so
proud of you that you got out there you
got the photo you snuck in and you
really you really made it happen and so
on this day we supplied a little
something special to honor you okay so
first one dollar bill oh wow and what
this symbolizes is that you are no
longer an intern you are a salaried
employee that you've officially been
paved okay
and then also here we've got ya Employee
of the Month into salaried employee
right here and here that's for you well
we're gonna put it up on the wall and
then here it says Employee of the Month
awarded to Ian the salaried employee
awarded by the ashley podcast well done
excellent work this month and you are an
example of you you are an example to
your colleagues keep it up proud of you
and that says employee not intern Oh
have you noticed so you are no longer
known as Ian the intern you are here for
known as
Ian the salaried employed congratulate
to spend it all at once don't blow up
you can still get demoted thank you
thank you thank you salaried employee
everybody
we appreciate it incredible yeah get out
get out yeah
thank you that was awesome and I am
really glad that you went yeah this
picture is fantastic I mean damn now we
have to address Ethan
every time we talk about Bill people get
upset why and comments because they
think that I am upset
oh you're upset because they think that
you're obsessed with bail well I
personally you're gonna make a joke but
I personally have no I don't see it that
way and I don't know why people see it
that way I think people just I mean I
play it up like that I joke yeah I asked
Ian how does she smell which is I think
for anything to ask but do you feel that
oh why do you have to ask that one I say
to you how did she smell
I don't yeah you shouldn't cuz I'm
joking and you're not insecure you're my
wife of seven years and you know that
I'm just kidding around that I don't
actually want to [ __ ] bail I feel like
even though what she does is
pornographic we can appreciate the
hustle Oh
which is worse we boat and by appreciate
you mean no no I've never jerked off to
bail delphine point it's not my cup of
tea the whole although she scares me
honestly she scares me a little bit I
feel like she's so freaky that um like
on her patron I said she's into daddy
Dom I was like oh god I don't even hey
she wants me to roleplay as her daddy no
no dad's involved here well actually
when we have sex now illa it is kind of
daddy Dom because
I'm dad now but yeah I mean I don't know
if people are serious but yeah I don't
know but I keep seeing it every time so
I feel like I should say something just
so people know so I I kind of feel like
it's hey I don't know to me it seems
clear but I guess it's not to everybody
I can't I don't know if they're kidding
either but we're all just having fun
here obviously in some of them aren't
from what I've seen it seems pretty
serious Oh for real
yeah people getting upset about it yeah
Oh what are they saying like just like
that you're the US would hurt yeah I
didn't know about that yeah
oh well chill out idiots find yourself
getting offended on behalf of somebody
else in a relationship take take a step
back that's like it that's an insult
comment yeah who's like I wouldn't if I
had either I would never treat her that
disrespectfully it's kind of insulting
to everyone in my opinion to assume that
we can't first of all that we can't
appreciate what she does because it's
pornographic and immediately means that
you just are obsessed with her you know
it can be separated and second of all I
don't know I like what she does yeah
it's the same people who are like anti
twitch thought is this is crazy and sell
these these dislike really toxic thread
through these are lonely pathetic men
who who think that having a pair of tits
is the ultimate trump card in life and
they're first of all pissed that they're
able to make money by being hot girls
and second of all that they don't get to
[ __ ] them and so they see you as a hot
girl first of all on top of all that and
how dare I disrespect you if you were my
girl I would fist you every night that's
what they imagine it feels good dancers
yeah I mean it's got that must be
someone who really has no maturity on a
relationship level we're here in a
podcast we're having fun we're having
last
yes if Belle Delphine was close to me I
would smell her hair that doesn't mean
that I don't love Elin that I wouldn't
cherish each I want to continue the
church Eli's my wife hard there you say
that doesn't mean that if I heard Bell
Fein like pass gas that I wouldn't
pretend to go tie my shoelace and smell
her ass that that doesn't mean that I
don't love my wife doesn't mean
immediately that I would cheat on Belle
Jaden he'll I mean I feel like we've
talked about it before we we appreciate
what she does I think she's a really
funny entertainer you don't see a lot of
strong powerful females and that I think
that's what she is and I don't and I
think it's just full well like there was
all these super angry in cells that
master an Instagram account yeah it's
like bro why are you angry just get like
seriously get a [ __ ] life if you're
actually angry that she trolled you with
the fake porn bro
oh my god try explaining that to a
significant other why are you upset
because this poor girl I like trolled me
on the internet she's just gonna post
porn but she only posted a picture of
her actually eating the cream pie so I'm
getting a cream pie bro you have you
know in cells is the new terrorist
organization there's more shootings
performed by in cells then freakin
Islamists in this country confirm that
to agree with that Dan but there's more
in cells than Islamists doing mass
shootings no doing mass shootings in
America oh yeah I don't think there's
been any Islamist area so mass shootings
I mean I'm pretty sure that's not true
either but you're probably right about
there being more I can't recall Oh
what's there I can't recall it's always
so many nice you know yeah oh yeah
you're right now if that was an Islamist
so they do get one point for that
congratulations as long as I look it's
unfortunately hard to keep tabs on them
all yeah I can't rattle off the top of
my
they're out there there pass dude yeah I
don't get the whole insult thing it's
just it's so it's like bro just if you
weren't so pathetic it's almost like the
chicken and egg they're so pathetic that
they can't get laid
it's like just stop being so pathetic
and you will get laid yeah do you know
what I'm saying
Zack what we're off the rails here yeah
congratulations bel the rails just broke
Dan yeah we're off the rails we're off I
want to show you guys a Turkish my boy
sees the end did some crazy watermelon
gags look at this [ __ ] dude the force
that comes out of that watermelon is
crazy
Oh Miley way exciting development here
did you look at the description to watch
description of this post what he's got
English
can you guess what is inside my
watermelon oh [ __ ]
I think we're single-handedly
responsible or him branching out to the
English community you know I was I was
on his page and he deleted a lot of his
videos yeah one day ones with the sad
face bro I've noticed a lot of people on
Instagram
the only on the soft brain I've noticed
a lot of people on Instagram deleting
their old pages that I don't understand
why Oh Instagram you're really gonna
play like that alright won't eat my dick
eat it so what was this a watermelon
video is this a science
yeah sinus channel he's branching out
we're doing it all man but I'm I'm
shocked at the force of that explosion
oh yeah that's that's really something
step back there damn look at that [ __ ]
alright I mean it's still blowing up
thanks man I did it
it's probably just uh like the mentos
trick but look at the foam knots so much
[ __ ] it's falling it's so much fun
and it looks really cool graduation is
czn for stepping up his game once again
can we try that yes absolutely down
looking to that I really we should for
the charity stream make Joey solid stand
over it looking in I don't know there
have been questions about Joey solids
you know if to include him yeah white
just because he's like a neo-nazi and
well we always humiliate him as part of
the show it's always that it's always to
his detriment like he suggested he
wanted to set himself on fire this year
and make it look like an accident I was
like I'll let me see if that's covered
on my insurance Joey yeah what's to
dislike about Joey salads there's no
incited race Wars I like how he's become
like a trump reply guy now yeah exactly
because applies to everything Trump ever
posts he's promoting his run for
Congress or something cuz he'll he'll
like suck Trump's dick immediately with
some like immediate comment and then
under his comment we like support me for
my run for Congress and then under that
is just 500 pictures of him pissing him
naked pissing in his own mouth it's so
funny it's the best ever but he's
getting out photos a lot so if Joey
actually wins a seat and Congress I
think what do we do about that move I'll
have to run against him and then
following a like that
no not moved an action starts here we
must be the change that we see in the
world
I will unseat him that would be [ __ ]
loves off we might need to do a vote or
something and make a decision cuz it's
becoming a big decision if to have Joe
solid yeah I think the vote overwhelming
yes but I'll let the people decide mmm
good there has been some concern
expressed from the understood
participants their life stream I want to
help them like that I didn't say who
yeah
I went out like that but I mean from
fans as well that's ooh why don't we
make a strawpoll and put it in the
description and everyone who gets this
deep end go to the description unfold it
and then you'll see a strawpoll will say
should Joey salads be included in the
next charity stream and you can vote yes
or no
just remember if yes it will be
something like humiliating to him maybe
we'll make him drink his own piss again
well maybe eat his own doodoo when he
was when he was puking that was some
funny [ __ ]
you see Thank You Zach he was in a damn
pool of milk what do you guys vote Danny
and Zach you know what my vote is don't
I
I don't think politics should be brought
into it I don't think so if we keep it a
non political arena yeah yeah we got a
no we got it yeah he's funny I like Joey
as a person on a personal level and I
can't think about it um I'm not sure
I got a mullet over yeah weigh all the
pros and cons on this one I mean if
people don't want him here than that I
feel like the vibes gonna be off you
know yeah it's all about the vibes Ethan
come on arguing because we want to be
happy
charity all right so then Zach you've
all heard of eat uh - uh Joey Danny you
Altair old Antony the mayonnaise cake
yeah if if it's for a good cause I will
yeah I'll do something I'll do some
crazy I am gonna puke live on it maybe
maybe we should all we we can we can
donate for you to taste it and then
donate again when you're pure mmm cool
we should devise maybe something
terrible for all of us to do yeah and
then so at each milestone we yeah do
something horrific like somebody should
hit me full yeah I heard that that's
okay we
in your own mouth I mean how can we show
that do you planning on ever running for
Congress ya know if you do it anything
for the show you're planning to be
Attorney General like what I'd like to
do is maybe hit the Gatsby full-speed
into a wall
oh man that's old news dude no but
you're right but it's been done but
nässjö huh I'll do it harder but not
like retention no like straight into a
wall yeah intentional straight into a
wall faulty people should suggest what
each of one of us thank you
yeah I don't know what mine would be but
I'm down to debase yourself in somewhere
like that something yeah something all
right but if it is for a the right
dollar amount and anything for the show
I will take a sip of urine was that I
don't think anyone actually wanted to
see that but I have a dollar exactly I
wanted I wanted to have touched on this
last episode but we had this wonderful
moment from Bobby Lee and kalila is
where Dan interrupted to go to break
during one of the most touching
heartwarming moments the Bobby Lee had
used to pray and really believe in God I
used to go God please kill this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know hey guys I'm so sorry to
interrupt we got to go to break
[Laughter]
that was such a fantastic moment I could
tell you we're in on him by the way you
actually yeah yeah hey guys I'm so sorry
to interrupt we gotta go to clean sound
bite I got hate for that it was so hate
POTUS on the subreddit but not really
did they get a lot of traction no I
it was my responded actually you did a
rookie Missy don't respond owner up we
gotta go to break
[Laughter]
I definitely pushed Dan to do it but his
timing was like superb
there was no good time there was so
heavy yeah cuz I I was the I knew
you need to go to break but yeah only it
was like he was really getting some
heavy stuff there actually we had I had
people who were fans of his shows who
are friends of mine who were saying
they've never seen him get that real
before even on his show yeah and so Dan
kind of totally [ __ ] that up
it was a great episode and but it was a
great moment then thank you for your
service you did hey guys I'm so sorry to
interrupt we got break anyway we had a
it generated a lot of great memes review
with you oh yeah the Walter Cronkite the
president has been Dan we go we got to
go to break the answer to life is but
you should hit me with the soundbite
Zach we got to go to break
you got it hey guys I'm so sorry to
interrupt we don't know right we gotta
go to break do you have the technology
it just says yeah we've got acknowledge
it to cut out a go to break yeah
you ready Zach yeah the answer to life
is so sorry to interrupt we got to go to
break coming a little bit earlier a
plane has crashed into the world I go to
break there you go Epstein didn't commit
suicide Alan came yeah Epstein didn't
commit suicide
what's going on you're just pushing a
button I don't understand interrupt we
gotta go to break
what is really happening at area 51 is
so sorry to interrupt we got to go to
break
Zach you gotta cut him off you gotta cut
him off dude what's going on Obama's
last name is already interrupt there you
go I don't get that one I think it's
just cuz it's stupid because his last
name is Obama it's it's all I've seen
people repeat oh my dad dies already
interrupt
the P is stored I'm having a stress
Abraham Lincoln is already interrupted a
break four scores in all right now you
just push that here's a Kanye
interrupting was it Taylor Swift yeah I
include the little caption so sorry to
interrupt
yo Bobby I'm really sad for you and I'm
gonna let you cry but we just got to go
to commercial make right now
ela can I drop the n-bomb what's the
n-bomb
just no Ethan don't mozzarella break
time Wow write this here all right we're
duty bound to report it so that's a new
one eh
I like it honestly you like that I love
it
can we get done with honestly so that
was a great thing for that you don't
have any sound bites of me
and I don't know how I feel about that I
have the the what up big pimp Sena
that's true that's true but those are
all good the gun shot is so good
I can I can find them just like yeah or
what is it the people say you say yeah
right yeah yeah yeah honestly there's a
couple of those stories here I saw this
I was browsing Facebook and one of my
friends mom said I grew up with Thomas
[ __ ] you guys fail oh no I can't open it
cuz Facebook makes you log in all right
that's the dumbest [ __ ]
there was a deep fake I wish I could
show to you guys it was a scene from The
Shining where they superimposed Jim
Carrey's face over Nicolas Cage's face
and it was obvious that it was a deep
fake because it was like scene for scene
and I had like 20 million shares of all
these Facebook moms going Wow Jim Carrey
is so talented he totally and I'm like
god that's scary and I'm like yeah it's
scary it was all these moms that didn't
know that it was fake by the way sorry -
I was done talking up we gotta go to
break yeah whisky you skipped over the
Halloween planning was that on purpose
or did you forget because no Halloween
planning well we are gonna plan for
Halloween special segments how's that
going to end we want to get I want to
send into a haunted house to get into
like one of these really scary ones you
know what I'm saying where they have
like chainsaws and [ __ ] are you okay
with that Ian
yeah and um and thank you he's into this
and I want to spend the whole crew to
the Queen Mary absent clearing all of us
yeah all of us so I'm gonna go although
in fact I'm thinking even to get a
cameraman so we can all be on the mime
row yeah your bro is gonna record are we
gonna sleep there no I just want to do a
tour I want to find I got time for this
[ __ ] where is it the Queen Mary thing
that you're talking about is a haunted
house you can all it's kind of the same
thing oh no no there's no it's the boat
itself is supposed to be creepy and
weird but it's not like jump scares it's
just like during Halloween that it is
like jump scares there's normally like
the ghost tours there yeah but during
Halloween they turn it I think it's I
think it's outside the I think it's
there but outside the boat it is haunted
well if it's a jump scare I don't want
to do it I'm not doing it
why I just don't think we would be able
to capture that - well we got to do it
within by like all of us it's good point
a lot of those I worked one years ago at
Six Flags a couple years in a row and
they they don't let cameras in well we
need to reach out we if anyone works at
one of these haunted houses please reach
out to us
because we need some special permission
to record there but I wonder if you
could give them a call down and see if
anyone's down just say hey we're from
they shoot podcast we are the most
popular show on the planet we have all
over the streets they're saying that
yeah yeah ask anyone on the street we've
got millions and millions of views were
highly respected in all entertainment
circles we've had bill burr brock obama
george w bush senior really we've had
Roseanne Barr
would that be like though we do the
whole episode from the boat or I think
it would be it I think we would make a
segment and then we'd have an segment at
the haunted house and then we will
comment on it so it'd be like 50%
segment 50% us commenting on the segment
okay sounds fun yeah Halloween
spectacular let's do it we don't much
time so I guess so we got to rattle this
a couple week we have all the DAGs so
it's a day trip it's here in Long Beach
oh okay yes close couple hours not even
it's yeah it's relatively close i think
i'm unspookable
so I'll be interested to see me too I
mean not jump scares and chainsaws I
don't like all that stuff but like in
terms of like creepy ambiance unless
yeah I'm fine I think that I'm
unspookable so I'll be going in there I
think all three of you guys are gonna
get extremely spooked though why I know
I know Ian and Zach will dance Dan I'm
less sure about well I got a question I
don't believe in ghosts oh no not really
you guys asked like ghost story
questions but like do you guys believe
not now if the show that's why we'd
never like that segment even though the
fans like it because it's always the
whole time you're just thinking this is
[ __ ] yeah I'm like yeah I'm thinking
this person's before all crap and I
always preface it was saying I don't
believe in any of this [ __ ]
and it was a deal with everybody got
angry at me because I wasn't taking it
seriously
yeah well we went to like the scariest
place it was so dumb the devil's job
doubles devil's [ __ ] some scary
places in the middle of the night and
there was nothing there except some
critical noises and crickets and and
then what they do is they whip out these
like apps it's like yeah on the App
Store is gonna be picking up ghost
sounds and it's like over like the extra
backdoor detectors ago I I second bells
when I was a girl whoa crazy that goes
just said he sucked balls when he was a
girl I said you think it's so stupid why
you want to do this Queen Mary I think
it'll be funny I think it will be funny
I think that it will be funny cuz I'll
go there unspookable where I went with
post he wanted to be spooked he wanted
to believe I did not want to believe I'm
unspookable but what if I do get spooked
that's funny that's ten so there's a lot
of happening but Ian and Zak will be
scared I think Dan the ghosts will get
to Dan
I think that really gets me wet how how
are you and Zach feeling about ghosts I
don't think we've ever discussed not um
yeah your spook well here's something
Halloween is my favorite holiday but as
far as like Paranormal Activity I don't
know if I necessarily believe in it I'm
just scared of it scared of it being
real
hey no he's something well I mean yeah
he entertains you can have a hard time
in there Ian I don't believe in any of
it I think I'm unspookable Wow
well no it'll be interesting we're all
unspookable except Zach you know we
should do it going through and then all
of us stop walking and then Zach starts
wondering like for a minute by himself
and he goes guys and then we're all gone
just [ __ ] with Zach yeah do you think
that place you went to cuz you were in a
group it made it less scary they were
trying to be scared I don't know I mean
if I was by myself I'm well if I was by
myself I wouldn't even know that the
place was being haunted
I'm more scared of homeless people know
we're in the middle of the night yeah
I'm scared of tweakers hit is stabbing
with their AIDS needles I think more
than ghosts you know what I mean yeah
yeah I won't do like the jump scare
haunted house as well you know [ __ ] that
yeah always [ __ ] I don't have a hard
to turn that [ __ ] is not quite
Ian's can do that the salaried employee
right hand yeah right well I think the
Queen Mary will be fine has a better
suggestion for the Halloween episode
leave it in the comments if you do see
what you got
I think the Queen Mary will be fun maybe
we all go trick-or-treating I just go in
at diaper
I'm trick-or-treating I'm Bobo okay what
else we got here we're off the rails
fortnight is offline and people are
freaking out I guess it's back it's back
now but there was some funny things that
came out of
they I don't give a [ __ ] I can't talk
about this I really don't give a [ __ ]
people were crying kids were punching
the screen here's the kid punching his
screen this was funny I heard this is
what's going on here in the world went
four nights down you see you uh wait he
didn't even break the TV I thought he
broke the TV it's just a black hole
pretty cool oh it didn't break epic well
here's something we can end on where's
Noah Friday because we're moving it's
you know the guy who did the stop I'll
just turn it down the guy who did the
sub sub sub calm did the data every cop
I've ever done and it's guys got a lot
of free time
this guy's got so much free time I was
telling the guys here this is just the
soundtrack of my life there's a lot in
that video dude there's a lot of coffee
in that video really doesn't like Ethan
scoffing like the dogs can bark and is
unfazed and then Ethan coughs and he's
just like every time he gets startled by
it I don't know why this is pretty
interesting to watch I'm not gonna lie
it's like a buzz for the path
this guy really went through all these
huh
we're back
what's the duration on this video we are
Wow not even I mean we're only 1/7 the
way through 7 minutes so that's it hey
this it was a tube this video only has
300 views 295 not a lot apparently
people don't want to watch this - all
right well this way like we could use
this guy's uh expertise yo I wonder if
this guy wants to do highlights for us
Dan all right ribs Tibbs right - right
I see email it podcast at a space
reproduction comic damn we'll reach out
we have work for you you're hired
he says in the tub in common this took
four months of watching every single
issue I give them a dollar coughing
clips this is insane I need it's
dedicated in my life
can you imagine working for months and
it just has two hundred ninety five
years it's a super fine really
yeah we need this maybe just published
it I got some news after this it it was
published three days ago there you go
that's not a lot of use for three days
of work but anyway I need someone this
dedicated in my life for sure okay let
me skip to the end and see I'm College
oh he went through Ethan in yellow too
so we're not gonna have some Friday
cause we're moving we'll have a little
scoop on that later better I'll tell you
more about that I'll talk about it later
yeah but yeah we're moving and so we're
not gonna be unfair do you have any
guests next week or anything damn well
and we were supposed to have Tricia I
don't know that's I think she'll accept
my apology we'll see yeah well it was
hard film uh-huh well what's the first
cough ever let's find out let's go to
the very end
shirtless the tie wow that's old as [ __ ]
it was always there that was it yeah
bell pepper oh yeah
that was it Wow when I was a there's the
first time I did anything funny I feel
like with the bell pepper and we've
filmed that more like that was pretty
funny and there was like this bell
pepper that looks like an anus that was
like so putrid and it was making me gag
every time look at our room
I kept wearing a torn shirt look at my
desk can't even fit anything on there he
said I Nate it we had so little space
you know damn it was a real one you
could tell but she was with me even back
then yeah this guy went deep
damn the quality is so bad
all right that's it guys have a great
week we can keep slamming keep bow I am
and keep slamming keep blaming I have
apologies to issue I apologize to Trisha
Paytas for calling her hey I don't
believe I called her beached well I
think I just said she wrote she looks
like she washed up in the ocean I
apologize for that I apologize for
saying she looks like an open casket
corpse I apologize to Ian for calling
you an idiot that's not what I meant
all that was very rude very abrasive
that's not who I am it's not who I want
to be at least it is Who I am but it's
not where I wanna be
so Ian I apologize I respect you and I I
just I I mean the show won't be the same
without in the salaried employee so
thank you to Ian thank you to Dan take
it as AK then what do i what do I call
them you described him as grizzle Grey's
'old right apologies to Dan for
describing as grizzled and old that's
fine oh you have Pete apologize yeah I
didn't think so
that's real I thought people made some
funny analogies to the office if I'm
Michael Scott people are saying that Zac
is Ryan because I was referring to him
as young and green and Dan is Toby and
Ian is uh who's Ian oh he's gem then you
know who you are
Ella you're Dwight you're definitely the
white you have to be I love that I
[Music]
thought I was gonna get where I'm
Michael you have to be Dwight that's the
perfect honored to be Dwight so we need
to hire more people to complete the
analogy hopefully like 20 more yeah
we're definitely missing a Creed and
we're missing a
I mean I think without a costume pretty
much yeah but that made I think we got
the majors covered we just need a Creed
so who is Toby then Dan stubby hmm
for sure yeah oh well thank you guys if
you want to extend this analogy please
feel free to leave a comment if you I
don't know there's a pen I don't know I
don't know guys I just what can I say
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
got to go to break you want to say
anything you know mm-hmm damn it Zach
Ian and won't got anything to say have a
great week everybody
Ian great week great week everybody
that's the net that's though Nate word
of the week great week thank you
everybody for listening this has been
another episode of the HDTV podcast
worldwide Tata
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]